let's start with katy perry who is
definitely feeling a range of emotions
right now
katie's pregnancy bloom is up first in
tonight's snow and tell
and a live stream shirtless dad to be
orlando interrupted katie's live stream
with a kiss while holding her dog nugget
bloom tried to fill katie's pregnancy
cravings
i'm so hungry honeydew what do you want
no i'm fine thank you fans remembered
that orlando recently mourned the loss
of his dog mighty
this weekend both orlando and i have
felt a little bit blue
i think it's because of mighty and maybe
because he was
orlando was watching six episodes of
ozark in a row
it's pretty dark
there i am still heavily pregnant
showing off her growing baby bump katie
announced she'll be holding her smile
sunday's live stream each sunday until
her album comes out on the 28th
but could the baby girl she's nicknamed
kiki perry
come early my child has hiccups
she literally has got hiccups in my
belly right now
she's literally like
so i'm gonna go and feed myself which in
turn will feed her
now to chris pratt and catherine ready
to pop that's how the dad to be
captioned this pic
he and his very active nine months
pregnant wife catherine took a hike on
saturday to the top of the mountain
chris joked he wasn't ready for the
birth just yet quote
kind of grateful it didn't go down on
the trail though to be real
and it's double baby boys for the bella
twins
i will not be shocked if her and i both
go in labor on the same time i know i
know
me too well close the sisters gave birth
just one day apart nikki's little boy
came first
both moms posting nearly identical shots
of their infant son's hands
no names have been announced yet but
back in june they told us this
we really want to name him after brian's
dad who passed
so big betty [ __ ] you said that you
have
to go by russian tradition so what is
that you always take the father's middle
name
and then you add with certain things
whether it's a boy or girl at the end of
it
[Music]